[Música]
reunimos a siete porristas soy una
porrista soy una porrista soy una
porrista soy un porrista soy una
porrista
uno de ellos miente si el grupo descubre
quién es el mentiroso se repartieran el
premio en efectivo
si el mentiroso sobrevive él o ella se
ganará todo el premio quien es el
impostor
[Música]
nombre en equipos donde han estado y en
qué posiciones base punto trasero ha
volado alzheimer edit anime a los
california all starz por cinco ejes
pensé que meredith no era una porrista
porque tiene uñas largas y siempre
hacemos puños y eso lastima la piel me
llamo anaya fue porrista por 9 años en
la escuela y model & para bar city el
catálogo de ahora mi nombre es home que
estoy en cal state fullerton y
actualmente estoy ahí tengo hay unos
tres años y su punto trasero central y
lateral hola soy diana fue porrista en
la universidad fui base y voladora hola
soy alex y fue porrista en la escuela y
un año en la universidad pero luego tuve
que mudarme y regresar a universidad
estatal de california pero los créditos
de la universidad no contaron entonces
fui entrenadora de acrobacias mis lava
bajo presión me puso nerviosa y decía oh
dios mío tenía que ir y decir algo pero
en el momento se me olvidó lo que iba a
decir oh no se me olvide o soy sábana he
sido porrista toda mi vida desde niña
estuve no estar en show calce let y
ahora soy porrista en la escuela soy
voladora por cierto mi nombre es el hijo
y porrista en la escuela y en all-star
que es lo que más te gusta que somos
como una familia competir me gusta lucir
y trabajar duro el estilo deportivo me
gusta lucir linda también
[Música]
tenemos un empate el empate es entre
alexis y diana cada una tendrá 20
segundos para demostrarle a los demás
que son porristas que quieren que haga
algo y baile de porrista hace tiempo que
no lo hago diseño
gracias es porrista o bailarina porque
lo que hizo fue más un baile y no tanto
como porrismo más que todo hice
acrobacias en el gimnasio de oyster
athletic ser enseñaba a los niños
pequeños les mostraré ahora mismo linda
bien
asombrosa
alexis o el salto hacia atrás y me
desconcertó un poco porque al inicio
había votado por ella muy bien
lo siento
fue un poco lamentable todos llevaban
zapatos de porrista o atuendo de
práctica y yo vine vestida muy normal y
esta será la ronda de porras
de verdad podemos hacer estiramientos sí
[Música]
no no
y en defensa me equivoqué puedo
repetirlo
y en defensa ataque
vamos
como lo hizo muy bien me encantaron sus
movimientos escuché que estaban
admiradas porque el toque de mi dedo del
pie era super alto también es una lengua
gol
ánimo muy bien vamos
voy a hacer como un baile de porrista
porque tengo demasiadas lesiones y no
puedo hacer más nada
[Música]
todos los apoyamos
son los líderes del juego a te hace a
ataca ataca ataca vamos granada
el mío es un poco más simple sólo voy a
hacer un estiramiento
puedo hacerlo de nuevo
lista
ella solo hizo el arco y la flecha fue
muy rápido y creo que todos estaban
intentando mostrar sus habilidades se
hicieron un canto o su canción de lucha
[Aplausos]
y el gol
así es luchamos todos juntos vamos que o
el gol juntos goleamos si ganamos vamos
westwood
la animación que hizo parecía más un
baile que una porra
[Música]
y sé que lo que hice salió fatal no
tengo más nada que decir si desean
seguir jugando levanten la mano en
de acuerdo es la mayoría han hecho
competencias y en cuales han estado
estado en sharp james y la n sea si
heinze a américa grande de américa que
eran sí sí yo también cuál es tu equipo
de porristas favorito al ico et
totalmente
de qué trataba la película ciro el
programa
el programa antes pero ahora vivo claro
ella era genial yo quería ser como ella
cuando era mucho más hold alimentación
es la peor lesión que has tenido deudas
fui a fisioterapia por muchos años por
mi cuenta conmoción cerebral hace un par
de años tuve que dejar de fumar por eso
en nuestra yendo escenario de la n sea
una niña es una canasta y yo estaba
detrás a sus tacones se clavaron en mi
cabeza me pasó algo parecido me dio la
nariz sus sueños estaban tan afiladas
que me das por andar y días
todos se les rompe la nariz ya tienen
torcida este de son voladores cierto
pueden hacer el arabesco o él es árabe
ya no soy tan
esperado de nuevo porque no apunta con
el dedo del pie
los zapatos christian dior
sentí que todos estaban un poco más
hacia este lado y yo estaba por fuera yo
estaba tratando de incorporarme a la
conversación sin presionar o exagerar
mis padres no saben que soy porrista en
6 y no tenían uniforme deportista porque
lo guardé bien no escondí pero luego mi
papá lo voto y empecé a buscar dónde
estaba la bolsa y dijo la vote pensé que
no lo usabas estaba pasmado dije ahí se
fueron mil dólares en mi uniforme
cuáles son los london si una vez sumamos
cuánto costarían para todo el equipo y
eran miles de dólares sobrando y en
lazos que usas donde más es el deporte
más caros y así luego algunas personas
creen que es por abismo no es un deporte
porque creen que sólo estamos en las 100
caer controversia pero siento que en la
escuela no es gran cosa porque no
compites por algo si depende de
ese y ese por ejemplo yo competí en la
escuela secundaria quedó minuto en
arizona para una escuela cuando compiten
son muy buenas de verdad no creo que
haya nadie aquí tampoco creo que haya
nadie aquí yo tampoco pensó que fuera
ninguna de ellas y así
una de ellas
en vez de otra cosa por eso era muy
sospechosa y además
no voten por mí no soy yo
pasamos a otra ronda así que solo escogí
a la persona que pensé que era menos
convincente
[Música]
todos lo siento más justo
y si desean continuar el juego levanten
la mano en
pareces un poco sospechosa no sé por qué
ya tengo una corazonada no sé por qué es
sospechosa tal vez piensan que solo me
puse una sudadera y vine aquí y si la
luz cambia a verde significa que
eliminaron al impostor y ganaron si la
luz cambia a rojo significa que el
impostor sigue adentro y perdieron
esta tarde
pero
siento que
existe conocida cuando entras te el
impostor puede dar un paso al frente
para revelarse en 3 2 1
[Música]
y
como un baile por eso pues con eso no
hacía gimnasia
jubilee vive intensamente